on pourrait croire à une plaisanterie
mais la décision du maire de cerdon est
très sérieuse avec un arrêté portant
interdiction de neiger sur sa commune
marc chavent veut interpeller le
gouvernement sur une situation difficile
à laquelle lui et ses administrés
doivent faire face aujourd'hui suite à
de fortes chutes de neige notes tracteur
de déneigement qui est vieillissant est
tombé en panne et puis nous avons eu des
branches qui sont tombés sur les lignes
haute tension et le village étaient
privés d'électricité les habitants
étaient très mécontents je les comprends
parfaitement parce que moi aussi je vis
ici et moi aussi les routes sont
impraticables pour moi également et je
n'avais pas de courant non plus
indispensable pour saler et déneiger les
routes le tracteur est désormais
inutilisable
après 30 années de service il est trop
abîmé selon le maire il est impossible
d'engager des réparations faute de
moyens et encore moins de le remplacer
donc un tracteur plus le chasse-neige
plus le chargeur on arrive vite 9 à
150000 euros et d'occasion à 80 milles
donc c'est vrai que pour une commune si
on dépense 80 mille euros pour notre
tracteur c'est un autre projet qui ne se
fera pas
marc souvent se dit abandonnés par les
pouvoirs publics il estime qu'il ne
devrait pas avoir à choisir sur quel
projet investir lui qui espère aussi
sauvé l'épicerie de la commune
malgré la curiosité que suscite la
médiatisation de son arrêté municipal
il n'a reçu aucun appel de la part de la
préfecture ou même deux candidats à
l'élection présidentielle